[Music]
you tweeted a picture of yourself
recently that got my attention it's you
with a with a dolphin you don't look
happy in this this is supposed to be a
situation I think where you're happy at
dolphins kissing you
well different less mammal yes well
let's let's be honest okay everybody
knows that dolphins erases everybody
everybody knows I didn't know you're not
everybody yeah so I'm there right and I
didn't want to go I didn't I didn't want
to go do it but I'm with a bunch of
women you know say like oh my god we
should do it it's gonna be so much fun
so my ad you know there's so much other
stuff to do cuz I know this is gonna be
great and we do it so like the
instructor guy for some reason my only
gasps he wants to start with me
yeah is that come on you first ask Oh
get in the Dolphins great he's gonna
take you around I think I I really want
to do it he's like come on the girls I
can okay so I girls are energetic so I
get in and like he's making a dolphin do
all these like face tricks to me like
he's like hey he tell the dog he's like
getting the kids and doves like and
comes up like but he sticks his tongue
out and I can literally see like I can
see his teeth like he had like a
thousand teeth so I'm looking at him and
he's like he's trying to tongue kiss me
and I'm gonna go I don't want to do it
no more so in the picture it looks like
I'm playing but like literally I got
frantic for a second right it was only
like three feet but in my mind
I thought I don't think that's racist
first of all he's you didn't see what
the dolphin did when I got there okay
we're not the tone of his